it is my great honor and my great
my mentor my friend Joseph Russo Joe
Russo earned his bachelor's degree at
Brooklyn College and then he came here
in a very heady time at Yale University
where he earned his PhD and then was
hired on as an assistant professor
reaching the rank of associate professor
without tenure before Joe went a little
bit south to Haverford where he is now
and I'm never gonna remember this if I
don't read it the Audrey and John do so
emeritus professor of humanities and
classics there was also a side trip to
Michigan I believe for a year among
Joe's many works that have helped me
along the years I think of course he is
one of the co-authors of the Oxford
commentary to the Odyssey I would like
to note anyone working for the library
his name is not mentioned with that and
I find that rather strange what is
mentioned of course is a collection of
Sicilian folktales translated with Jack
sites which Joe did after he retired I
recommend that as well and since I am
the student I would the many articles I
would just like to bring to one is a
personal favorite and one is probably a
well-known classic the well-known
classic is the structural formula and
Homeric verse yell Classical Studies I
thought this is volume 20 1966 edited by
none other than Geoffrey Kirk and Adam
Perry my personal favorite is Odyssey
1940 442 443 I still have the copy from
our seminar many years ago the bore in
the bush formulaic repetition and
narrative innovation in a fest refer
none other than Brunel champion
I am also into position and we don't
often get to do this to speak of Joe as
a teacher so with Joe you will indulge
me and you all indulge me I would like
to say a few words about teacher I'm a
bit of authority I have rarely had a
more knowledgeable and kinder teacher
than Joe Russo I was very very lucky to
have Joe not many graduate students got
to work with him an authority not other
than Peter Pucci who you all know is not
a man too
about many compliments once spent 20
minutes telling me how lucky I was that
Joe had taught me homer Joe always left
the text at the center
you were never distracted away from
Homer so I thank you Joe for teaching me
in my opinion the two greatest poems
ever written and teaching me to
appreciate that and I thank you on
behalf of many other her students who I
sure would want me to believe this among
them I think was Walker and gave polyol
especially who always speak a few fondly
whenever you see you suggesting I don't
mean them a parachute joke but thank you
ever so much and I hope you know that I
work very hard that seems like you when
I think of how I teach you in the many
of these room I've taught you I hope you
know that Joe Russo was one of my role
models and we don't recognize that
enough sometimes I think so thank you
Joe and without further ado without
making it about me I introduced Joseph
Russo the ghost of Petropolis and the
language of Achilles
Wow good good stars
hope my voice holds out I have sometimes
vocal cord problems and I get a horse
but I have water I have a suck on I have
a good microphone and a receptive
audience and a topic I'm very happy
thrilled to be speaking about I'm very
very very happy that this memorial
lecture series has been created there
were no words to express how honored I
feel to be inaugurating it
I give heartfelt thanks to the
department's of comparative literature
and classics for their sponsorship and
to the many individuals involved in
conceiving and organizing this event
it's also a special event for me
personally to have in the audience this
one ever happened again probably my
oldest and youngest relatives my cousin
dr. Anthony result and my grandson
Phineas O'Brien I'd like to begin with a
few personal memories of my friends Adam
and Anna
then comes a lecture proper Adam and and
Perry leave a vivid impression because
they were lively and fun in an era when
many classical scholars were a bit
old-fashioned and you might say stuffy
and an Adam represented a new generation
with a new style they were wonderful at
entertaining and they lived they loved
good food it was the era when Julia
Child had just burst on our scene you
may know her primarily through Meryl
Streep's brilliant caricature in Julie
and Julia but my generation hung on her
cookbooks and her TV performances and so
everyone is into great fresh recipes and
and was a superb cook and was a huge
treat to be invited to their home I had
forgotten this one detail but my wife
Sally who reminds me they like to have
when you came in for a dinner on the
background not Bach or Mozart but Cole
Porter or jazz
so you got into a nice mood for dinner
they understood atmosphere they had a
bohemian streak especially Adam this
that quality comes through and both of
the memorial notices written by Eric
Havelock and Hugh Lloyd Jones Adam
seemed to carry a whiff of danger about
him righteous or Hugh and of course he
was too much in love with speed born in
Paris Adam carried a certain European
quality of Frenchness says Eric have
luck I say Adam had Flair you see Edna's
writing and a certain unorthodoxy
sometimes bordering on rebellion toward
the more ponderous aspects of
scholarship I remember once getting in
many many members have come back in the
last weeks I've been getting into the
filter elevator and they got on Adam and
an in the middle of an argument
nice little spousal back and forth and
Adam was commenting on the manuscript of
Anne's book blameless Augustus being
finished at that point and she was
responding that book goes through all
the occurrences of the word Newman the
epithet in Homer and it has appendices
of wordless as percentages usages I have
apparently found this kind of detail
tedious and it's interesting that also
Adam Anne was replying to Adam rather
tartly I remember then had a a sharpness
about her sometimes that if you wanted
to make your argument convincing you had
to support it with lots of evidence and
so it's interesting to note that in his
article on the language of Achilles a
classic and a much criticized article I
will talk about that a lot today it's
been criticized primarily for how few
the citations of evidence it has
instead of amassing lots of evidence
Adam relies on a brilliant idea and
flair and not to be recommended to
graduate students but I think it's not
not a bad thing to do when you're an
established figure and your name is
Perry the 1960 is days of my friendship
with Adam and Ann were exciting and
turbulent times in America and in New
Haven politically we had a university
president Kingman Brewster who made his
famous statement that he didn't believe
a member of the militant Black Panthers
could get a fair trial anywhere in
America some of you may remember that we
had at the Yale and New Haven a very
strong anti-vietnam war movements in
which I think classes contributed more
heads proportionally than any other
department that was my impression
besides a demand and
we had Marilyn Arthur Katz then was
later published the book Penelope's
renown we had Peter Rose was just this
year published a major book called class
in archaic Greece and many others we had
a good group of faculty and graduate
students in the famous anti-war march
and rally in New York at the UN Plaza
what good company I felt I was in to be
making history with the parries marching
down Fifth Avenue and then he's on 42nd
Street to the UN where we heard Martin
Luther King speak Adam was indeed
political a left-winger as Julius are
you annoyed Jones grumbles officially in
his introduction to Adams collected
papers he was active in the Democratic
Party's reform movement back in Eugene
McCarthy instead of Hubert Humphrey
because something was still tied to
Lyndon Johnson's war and could not cut
to continue the war as a candidate for
the Democratic Party
most radical and Adam went so far as to
run for alderman in New Haven on that
reform Democratic ticket few people
remember that but I do yell a most
radical of all was the committee of 1515
Yale professors three from classics who
joined the University chaplain William
Sloane coffin and dr. Benjamin Spock the
most beloved pediatrician in America
encouraging a draft resistance to what
was seen as a nun increasingly unjust
war our committee included Richard W B
Lewis a distinguished scholar of
American literature expert on Edith
Wharton and he wrote a beautiful book on
the city of Florence and included Holly
Stevens daughter of the poet Wallace
Stevens not bad company to be radical in
it's hard to find adequate words to say
what it felt like to be a budding Homer
aswer 'king in the peri tradition and to
have the mentorship of Adam the son of
the Moomin Perry who had revolutionized
our field by the comparative study of
Homer of serbo-croatian epic later
continued by Albert Lord how thrilling
it was to be a young scholar sitting at
a dinner party at the Perry's when
Albert Lord walked in and to hear adam
introduce professor lore to his young
son simply as the man who was with your
grandfather in yugoslavia and eventually
i've tried to add something to that
tradition of scholarship so now it's
time to talk about Homer the ghost of
Patroclus and the language of the
Achilles to make it clear what I'm
aiming at in this talk at has four parts
it runs about 48 minutes part one
describes some key contributions Adam
and and Perry made to Homeric studies
and then elaborates on Adams famous
essay the language of Achilles mark 2
asks if Adam really was wrong in
committing the dreadful linguistics in
of horf ism
part three goes into the specialized
language Homer uses to describe mental
activity
and the sound and unsound mind and part
4 explains Adams Achilles complained
about the trackless ghost in terms of
the analysis I've been developing Adam
Perry's essay the language of Achilles
and na Murray's book blameless against
this have become landmarks in America
studies so that maybe give you a short
description of how each work enlarged
our understanding and a Murray Perry
made a great attempt to crack one of the
oldest nuts in Homeric studies why Homer
uses the familiar epithet al-nouman
usually translated as blameless to
describe the villain against this in the
very passage that identifies him as an
adulterer and a regis ID the murder of
the king of ooo was his lovers husband
Adam's father Millman Perry who tried to
prove that Homer composed orally without
writing had argued that such traditional
epithets had lost their meaning over
time so he saw this use of bladeless as
one more example of an epithet chosen
for metrical convenience rather than
meaning but an amery examining all the
uses of a melon in Homer argue that it
did have meaning but not blameless in
the ethical sense because a mamonas
applied to so many people in Homer it's
unlikely that the poet meant every one
of them to be seen as morally blameless
a Murray's interpretation was that it
meant flawless in a physical sense so a
better translation would be handsome and
a word originally meaning handsome would
easily have evolved devolved into the
looser meaning fine or excellent and
that makes me think of our English
saying handsome is as handsome does is
love that that's every Amrish theory
scholars since then proposed other
interpretations and we're still not
certain what I mean one really means but
her detailed study which got rid of the
old incorrect meaning remains a landmark
in our field
and other important contributions
include the two in saw two insightful
essays on the psychology of Penelope one
titled the reunion of Odysseus and
Penelope and the other called the gates
of horn and ivory that's in yell
Classical Studies 1966 each of these
pieces was a big stimulus to an essay of
my own on these topics and so for two
publications that I especially like on
my own I owe a great debt to Eddie
Murray now part two
like all Homer ists of my generation I
fell under the spell of adam perry's
1956 essay the language of achilles has
been called the most influential 7 page
essay on homer ever written and
paradoxically it's widely considered to
be fundamentally flawed I'll try to
separate out the flaws and call
attention to the valuable kernel very
focused on Achilles speech in Iliad 9
with a hero angrily rejects Agamemnon's
offered to pay material compensation for
depriving him of his concubine Chris
Adams ingenious interpretation is one
that scholars still argue over the idea
that Achilles having seen the inadequacy
of the heroic code that equates material
gifts with personal worth is trying to
say no to all that but finds the
traditional language of epicness so
inadequate for expressing
anti-traditional ideas that he must
resort to straining and misusing that
language achilles asks questions that
have no answer and makea logical demands
this claim about the connection between
language and thought has huge
implications that led me to today's
topic where I'll be examining the
language of Achilles in another instance
where I believe language again is
inadequate to the statement it is trying
to make and ends up conveying oblique
meaning through its inability to name
things exactly Adam Perry claimed there
was a necessary connection in over
between language and worldview
Homer's characters are limited by what
can be said in their traditional in the
traditional Homeric diction they can
only speak the artificial language Homer
ease and this puts constraints on their
expression of value system and worldview
the language favours the familiar and
expected it makes it harder to
articulate what is untraditional or anti
traditional this is a very attractive
idea in the 50s it exposed a serious
problem inherent in movement parish
theory of an oral and thoroughly
traditional Homer today Adams argument
is generally considered faulty because
he leaves most of the Kelly's speech
unexamined short on evidence and because
his claim that language limits thought
looks like an example of the old Wharf
Ian fallacy September ought to define
and so his argument has been refuted
several times and yet it refuses to die
scholars serious readers of Homer still
cited with respect I will try to explain
why it still has value
the first reputation was published in
1970 by MD Reeve who faulted Adam Mary
for giving inadequate evidence to
support his claim since he quotes so
little of the speech only three short
quotes out of 120 lines of speech and
only two seems significant and they're
all in English not in Greek first Flair
he was he thought he was right they
could do what he wanted
first Reeve disputes Perry's claim that
Achilles is misusing language when he
asks the question why should Greeks be
fighting Trojans after all the syntax is
normal and the question is actually
answered at least on this matter of fact
level because of Helen the bigger
implication existential it is Adams
claim but it really doesn't buy that as
other critics have pointed out what
Perry is really identifying is a thought
alien to heroic perdition why should we
expect projects rather than an
untraditional language
there is another example of Achilles
finding a language inadequate to his
there was needs and thereby making an
impossible demand is more interesting
because it does reveal a misfit between
thought and language whether to
traditionally go together
Achilles says he will not be reconciled
and rejoined the Greek army until I came
m'gann gives back to me all the
heart-rending insult a literal
translation line 387 of book 9 but in
got oboz' and Amoy Domini teer Malviya
law been given language does seem
strained to accommodate unexpected
contents but Achilles wants to say and
the way all translations have it is a
talk at the memnon pays me back for all
the heart-rending insults a meaning that
we'd expect to be rendered in a
construction with the genitive case I
don't parry call this an impossible
demand because it cannot be met in a
world where the payback is material and
the feeling of insult is immaterial
having to do with emotion and spirit to
say that the material cannot make up for
spiritual loss is a new or prevent
profound thought foreign to the warrior
ethic claimed Adam Perry and when
Achilles tries to verbalize this new
idea with the words until he gives back
to me all the heart-rending insults it
sounds as if he's asking Agamemnon to
give him back more insults the same verb
apathy to me to give back was used in
book one to describe giving the priest
crises back his daughter it means to
give back something that was taken so
Achilles verbal formulation while
intended to ask for compensation for
insults can sound like he's asking for
more insults Perry doesn't specifically
point out this grammatical awkwardness
but it fits perfectly with his claim
that Homer makes Achilles strain
conventional diction because he's trying
to express unfamiliar ideas Reeve the
critic does notice the awkwardness but
doesn't realize that it actually
strengthens Perry's argument about
misuse
of traditional diction in a very
different kind of analysis of the
language of Achilles mothers in 1978 a
very thorough and statistical analysis
of the individual manner in which
Achilles uses language but we might call
Achilles idiolect James Redfield and
Paul Friedrich mention Adam Perry's
essay and dismiss it as Wharf Venus and
run wild they also complained that he
fails to distinguish language from
discourse and rhetoric nice fancy
distinction valid and still another
correction an attempt to complicate
there was another correction of atoms or
our argument by app David Klaus who
shared some years with me here in the
Yale classics department in his 1975
essay in T APA he complicated the
analysis by showing that contradiction
can be expressed in America language and
does exist in America thought the
fullest and best critique I've seen was
made by Richard Martin in his book the
language of heroes after the familiar
complaint that Perry gives to few
specifics Martin goes on to analyze the
formula rity of every single word in
Achilles long speech his conclusion is
interesting he shows that most of the
individual words are formulaic ly
familiar and used in their habitual
metrical slots but that they do not link
up into formulaic phrases as often as
expected
thus martin confirms that there is
something unusual about the language of
the kilise it has the odd effect of
feeling untraditional and traditional at
the same time and he ends up endorsing
Perry's insight that Achilles here
speaks differently from other people but
Martin finds that difference in
rhetorical performance finds that
difference to be in rhetorical
performance rather than language per se
and notes as did Friedrich and Redfield
that Perry doesn't distinguish between
language and rhetoric Martin also raises
the familiar complained about Wharf ISM
saying that Perry speaks of Achilles
untraditional language when he should be
speaking of his untraditional thought
this is a valid objection
only if you assume a priori with Martin
that language and thought can be
entirely separated but Perry's whole
point is the opposite they can't be at
least not in the artificial construct we
call Homeric poetry here is war fizzle
again the supposed weakness and Adam
Perry's argument I am going to argue on
the contrary that warf ism does have
some validity and can be a factor in
Homeric poetry so now into part two Worf
ISM and let me give this strange seeming
word and concept the attention it
deserves this strange English noun new
to some of you am I'm short so they took
to Phineas
it's made from from the name of Benjamin
Lee Whorf professional systems engineer
and part-time linguist who studied
Native American languages and concluded
that people whose language encodes
reality so differently from speakers of
English must also perceive and
experience it in a different way such as
Worf isn't in its original form the
language you use determines the way you
see the world in this simple and hard
version Worf isn't is nowadays generally
rejected our dwarfism has gone the way
of heart perry ism but there is a newer
softer version which i'm going to make a
case for we homers encountered old style
Worf ISM in the argument made by Bruno
Snell that because Homeric Greek lacks a
word for body or self these concepts
must be missing in Homeric thought this
is classic Worf ISM the language you
speak requires you to think and see the
world in a certain way and blocks you
seeing it in another way snow was
essentially wrong but the peculiarities
of her language for describing mental or
psychic phenomena which drew his
attention are worth examining American
language is such a perfectly made
product for describing its artificially
created fictional worlds the fit between
language and fictive reality seem so
tight that it's not easy to slip in new
and original words or thoughts that's
what Adam Perry was claiming and he
wasn't entirely wrong a new
rehabilitated dwarfism has recently been
advocated by a group of cognitive
psychologists and linguists they argue
that the language you used does incline
you or can may incline you towards
perceiving and describing the world in
certain ways and away from certain other
ways not forcing you one way and
blocking you the other way but a more
gentle kind of influence whereby one
language will make certain perceptions
and conceptions more difficult or more
easy to access than another language
will if you want to pursue this research
further I refer you to the book through
the language glass by the linguist guide
deutscher and journal articles by
cognitive psychologist
Lera Bordeaux d'sky of Stanford and by
others including one by Daniel casa
santo who is at the New School for
Social Research in New York right now
and it's my favorite title who's afraid
of the big bad Worf
these scholars represent language known
as a distorting lens like all dwarfism
but a subtle colouring element that can
give an extra dimension or tone to some
of our perceptions they cite many
experiments with a subjects perception
and description of time-space a volume
color musical pitch and so on are
affected by the vocabulary for these
phenomena deutscher also gives personal
anecdotal examples now he sees or feels
of the world differently when he's
speaking his two household languages
English and Hebrew but his most
intriguing evidence comes from studies
he cites of various non European
languages for example a native South
American language where every verb of
knowing believing estimating declaring
surmising has to be qualified by an
indication of just how recent or remote
in time this knowledge is the gradations
are many and by Western standards these
a simple native folk would be master
ystem ologists speaking this way
requires them to be more aware at some
level conscious semi conscious and
unconscious but aware that English
speakers then English speakers of just
how sure they are that they know what
they know there's another third world
language deutsche cites that would have
a speaker say instead of careful as a
scorpion knee or left foot careful
there's a scorpion north northwest of
your left foot
these people live with constant
awareness of campus orientation which
they refer to constantly in their daily
speech cognitively they are always
processing visual evidence for sunlight
and shadow and estimating accurately
where north south east and west are and
they bring this heightened awareness
into their language and I have other
reasons why I Alina Worf Ian regarding
the relation of the language to thought
George's
use of his own experience in the and
it's anecdotal evidence from my as a
bilingual speaker reminds me makes me
think of where I have felt the Worf Ian
effect in speaking I think speaking a
language that makes the distinction yes
so many do but English doesn't between
familiar and polite forms of addressed
for the second person singular well in
English we call to twying because we
don't have the native word for it
because we don't have the experience so
we didn't make up the word so we put we
borrow the French word I think it makes
you more sensitive to the kind of
connection you're having with your
address see I spent many an hour with
colleagues students friends and
acquaintances in Italy and France
speaking their language and found I was
more consciously calculating and knowing
just where a relationship stood than I
would be if I were speaking English and
just saying you because of having to
decide whether to use vous or to Orlais
or to and when to make the shift down
down to intimate still another argument
since the essence of the war feegan
claim is the non equivalence of
languages across linguistic leaders not
everything everything is not equal one
consequence then would be the
impossibility of a hundred percent
successful translation of anything into
anything especially poetry where the
creator of language has been really
careful to nail the reality but the
right word
it's often remarked that the English
were at home has no equivalent in many
European languages because it combines
the meaning of house the physical
structure with something more emotional
like hearth or familiar and welcoming
dwelling place and you may know Robert
Frost wonderful lines home is the place
where when you have to go there they
have to take you in so the sentence I
recently read a novel a well as very
novel a brother and I began calling
grandpa's house our home
could not be perfectly rendered outside
of English of course it could be closely
rendered almost the same meaning could
be arrived at by circumlocution and
adding extra words but the poetic effect
the parallel balanced mono syllables
house and home with alliteration is not
reproducible and the feeling level could
never be matched my view of the wharf in
effect includes not just how we see the
world but how the language we use can
embody and even stimulate our feelings
about it so accepting as I do the
inevitability of some degree of the
whorfin effect in language especially
poetic language I think it's reasonable
a reasonable claim that we find
something like that in Homer Creed Greek
epic language we've known for a long
time as an artificial construct with its
own preferred established ways of
describing the world on human thought
and action it takes special of effort to
go outside of or against it additional
and the poet will not always have the
time or energy to forge new language to
match new thought more likely he will
restructure familiar language into
slightly different patterns sometimes
awkward seeming as achilles claim that I
am in one give him back more insults and
so I see an unavoidable element of wharf
ism in the way Homer or his characters
are sometimes led by the epic language
to describe things in a way that strikes
us out
as peculiar elusive or oblique and when
it comes to describing certain subtle
aspects of human experience especially
complex emotional life epik language can
offer curious and big.you ''tis so now
for part 3 the language of mind one
source of such ambiguity is the
vocabulary Homer's tradition gives him
for describing mental phenomenon many
scholars have written about this
language based on words that denote some
kind of mental organs we call them a
famas cardia
care yet or menos and friend and it's
commonly used plural
Brenna's the nouns the most Katya care a
torrid menos can be translated as more
or less spirit heart impulse and frame
and friends curiously can mean either
mind or midriff they've been called
mental organs because all of these words
except menos designate both a physical
entity and a psychic the psychic or
emotional energy or process connected
with it get a little more comfortable
I'm interested in one term from this
group of mind words and the ambiguity it
can create and this will eventually take
us to the ghost of Patroclus the term is
Brenna is the plural of frame both
singular and plural means something like
mind or heart or these two ideas in one
the plural Furnas denotes intelligence
or awareness but requires different
translations in different contexts part
of this complexity comes from the fact
that the word clearly denotes both the
material and the non material entity the
physical meaning of fairness is midriff
or diaphragm and it might also refer to
the lungs in Illiad book 16 in the
description of Patroclus killing
Sarpedon Patroclus spear hits or beaten
just where the Fran is enclosed the
heart
and when Patroclus pulls out a spear in
line 504 Homer says he drew out the
spear from the flesh and the furnace
came with it whether specifically lungs
or not Ferran has a clearly soft tissue
in the chest enclosing the heart fact
the phrase the heart within the friend s
occurs a few times elsewhere in the poem
a thought any Frazee but most
occurrences of friends refer to the mind
and the general meaning is good sense or
wit's this noun frame is related to the
verbs for an arrow to think have in mind
intent and the verb phrase defroster by
to reflect consider so the core concept
here is thought and when foreigners are
conceived as physical they denote some
area in the chest where consciousness is
located and thinking is carried out
throughout Homeric epic we find the
plural friends sometimes denoting this
physical space or organ and more often
denoting the more abstract realm of
consciousness or alert awareness and
there are passages where we cannot
honestly tell if with the meaning is
more physical or mental or the tubing to
blended into one the physical as the
housing the mental so to speak perfect
example of the physical sense as the
locus for the psychic element is this
description of Agamemnon's anger in book
1 of the Iliad provoked by the Prophet
callouses revelation that Agamemnon is
the cause of Apollo's wrath and his
friend has black all around filled
greatly with anger many us that Megatron
is on Team Illini implant
you know the anger the emotion menos is
imagined as filling up this inner Oregon
the furnace which have turned black with
rage the orchid has definite physical
reality as it performs the psychic
function of holding the anger the purely
mental meaning by contrast
prefers normally to the quality of sound
mind a good example is Agamemnon's
evaluation of his new concubine Croesus
whom he does not want to give up and
compares favorably to his wife
Clytemnestra she is in no way inferior
neither embodies nature or mind here
called friends or handiwork
Oh demos would appeal an ogre fairness
oddity Erica taking sound mind as the
basic meaning of fairness helps us
understand many passages where an
acceptable behavior is attributed to a
character having no friends or weaken
for the nest Achilles is described by
Poseidon as having no friend has not
even minimal ones because he sits apart
from the action seeming to rejoice in
his heart at the deaths of the qiyan
warriors they avoid any fairness would
EDI ABI means flimsy minimal flighty and
unstable
that's book 49 141 similarly a person
who behaves foolishly or a warrior or
even a God whose rage for battle is so
strong it can be blamed as excessive is
called a fraud without good sense a
negative adjectives based on the known
frame I've given this range of meanings
and uses of redness to set up a problem
how do we understand the use of this
word specifically the claim that friends
are absent in the language used by
Achilles to characterize Patroclus
ghosts and so now we go to part for my
take on the language of Achilles we're
early in the 23rd book of the Iliad at
the story moving towards its close but
rockland finished Achilles to let him
fight in his place
since Achilles wanted to Hank
in his decision to spurn Agamemnon's
offer yet he was feeling increasingly
consistent concern for his fellow Greeks
as Hector had turned the battle to the
Trojans advantage so petrópolis enters
the battle we're in a kelly's armour
then Hector tells Patroclus with
Apollo's help and the Greeks recover the
corpse which has been lying unburied
Achilles has been weeping inconsolably
and is now emotionally exhausted at
lying asleep the spirit of GK of
Patroclus comes to him as if in a dream
and makes a speech asking for proper
burial so he can enter Hades when the
ghost vanishes Achilles tries to embrace
it but fails he is physically unable to
do so his hands touch nothing material
and as the image of his friend
disappears he exclaims so there still is
also there is still some spirit CP
surviving in Hades but there are no
complete fairness in it or you can
translate there are no finish in it at
all
depending how you choose to translate
the advert pompon oh boy arretez st chi
ni de ah da ma SI su ke kai a Dolan at
our friends Oconee company it's not
clear what in the ghost behavior or
speech reveal this lack of furnace the
interpretation is complicated slightly
by the advert pompon completely because
it can be taken two ways either
underworld spirits do not have complete
fairness but they do not have friends at
all this crux has troubled all
commentators beginning with the ancient
ones
Aristarchus wanted to delete the verse
since a him had made no sense
how has sound mine friend is lacking in
a spirit that has just spoken eloquently
making a cogent argument for proper
burial if we try to avoid the problem by
stretching the meaning of fairness to
spirit of life as does Lattimore for
example in his translation
apparently following Walter Leafs
commentary we give it a meaning it has
in norther place in Homer or you see it
or early epic for that matter life
animating spirit is regularly the moss
or bouquet and Homer are the words that
give us five us and psyche in English
and Homer several times says that one or
the other of these departs from the body
when a person dies or faints but rot
this
psyche to Kay the source of animating
life energy now separated from his
living body in coming back as a ghost
cannot be said to lack life energy
through a lack of fairness we must think
further about what it might mean for
Italy's to say that this psyche this PK
Lex finis Richardson in his Cambridge
commentary which was good almost
everywhere sees this problem clearly and
I think gets it wrong he finds an escape
via the alternative physical meaning
that friends can have the midriff thus
the difficulty Achilles has in taking a
hold of his friends image Richardson
concludes is because it has no mid-drift
or chest cavity the same explanation was
offered by surely darkest Sullivan a
decade before in her book psychological
activity in Homer a study of trained
Richardson doesn't show great confidence
in his interpretation and I'm not
surprised one's immediate reaction my
gut reaction it was it feels wrong and
then the mind begins finding evidence to
support the gut reaction it's wrong
because when Finnish denote the physical
structure we translate as midriff or
positively diaphragm or lungs
there's always something deeply internal
it takes a woman to get to it it's not
part of the psyche of the physique the
outer frame of the body the build which
is regularly denoted by a demos when
Agamemnon in book what is furious with
calculus and his friend has filled up
with angry spirit these friends seem
inside his body in the wounding scene in
book 16 but rotteness pulls out a spear
and the friend s come along with it that
only other friend is well inside the
chest
they are soft enough to slide out
through an open wound how did the sort
of firm organ you would grasp but when
expecting to take good hold of someone
well they would be a kind of squishy so
returning to Patroclus ghost I would say
that the deeply embedded midriff or
diaphragm are not the kind of foreigners
he lacks he must return to the non
material sense of friends and figure out
when achilles cannot physically grasp
Patroclus and keep him there what does
the disappointment that leads him to
complain that friend Azul Guinea bump on
there were no friends at all or not an
entire set of friends in this ghost so I
suggest we combine two kinds of evidence
what kind of behaviour in homers word a
world leads to the judgment that one has
incomplete or impaired friends and how
ghosts in homers underworld would
normally display their friends or sound
mind for evidence about the underworld
we have to go to the Odyssey books 10
and 11 and assume that the composer of
the Odyssey shares more or less the same
conception of the underworld of
underworld spirits as the composer of
the Iliad in addition was interview with
Tiresias in book eleven we have a long
and satisfactory dialogue between the
living and the dead no complaint here
about inadequate threateners the
relevant evidence comes from Circe's
prior description of Tiresias ghost in
book 10 as a dish uses being prepared to
encounter him she says you must go to
Hades to seek a prophecy from the psyche
of Theban Tiresias the blind seer whose
friend has our sound for to him alone
did Persephone grant a mind that is
intelligent even after death while the
others dart about like shot
as the Greek hazard gk craves on the
nost a bioterror CR monte us allahu to
that friends MP doy is he
knowing chi technorati known for their
savonia to him alone dare that did
Persephone give enormous mind or UI
peppiest i toid STI ie Suzy so in the
common belief was that spirits of the
dead normally have lesser or unsound
fairness but tiresias was made an
exception presumably because of his
special mental powers Achilles then
describing Patroclus ghost could be
voicing disappointment with the mental
capacity of dead spirits they simply
cannot perform what living people
endowed with fairness can they lack what
tiresias possesses knows the mind as a
faculty for planning and intending that
allows one to demonstrate real
intelligence the verb benveniste when
Patroclus ghost lacks is the capacity
for genuine dialogue you spent the night
grieving and complaining and then
vanished when interrogated thérèse yes
by contrast was able to engage in
sustained dialogue with Odysseus
answering his questions fully this
observation by itself may go some way
towards explaining the language of
Achilles complaint but we can go further
by looking at what the world of the
living considers unsound or inadequate
friends
we see this in complaints made about
Achilles in Paris in books 14 and 6 both
heroes are behaving unnaturally
lacking sound mind Achilles enjoying the
Greek defeat because it punishes I
commend non lacks the sound mind that
would make him feel natural sympathy for
his fellow Greeks and she is
characterized as having no friends that
even flimsy ones who Ferrara's Oh
the other complaint about weak friends
as Helens rebuked to Paris in book six
which uses negatively the same word
empathize sound they characterized the
fairness of Teresa's parish shows no
firm adherence to heroic standards
therefore he has unsound friend s
fairness book and Bedoya
meaning he is inconsistent not reliable
you cannot count on him to stay the
course and this I believe is the way it
Calise in book 23 sees Patroclus as
ghosts lacking the sound mind that
sustains the verbal give-and-take of
human interaction and would allow him to
be fully himself it would have been
helpful to us that the kilise could have
said this more clearly but he hasn't he
said it too concisely and obliquely and
that's what is troubled readers and
commentators the problem is that Homer's
characters do not have complex or
sophisticated language at hand for
critiquing a wide range of troublesome
mental states for unsatisfactory mental
states for a simple aberrations they can
call you add ammonia implying your
momentarily gripped by outside powers
and acting strange they can or they can
call you pronounced a lad by bringing
your wits they can fault you for not
complying with social norms acting in an
unseemly manner will there Erica or look
at a Cosmo but it becomes more difficult
to say that someone is not fully
themselves the personality isn't there
and this is what I believe Italy's is
trying to say about the tracklist but
Greek has no word for personality and
when Achilles speaks in friend's
language friends formulas the range of
what he can say is limited because he
has to say it in all Murray's a certain
degree of Warfield limitation is at work
he must make up a phrase that is not a
perfect translation of his thought
but we always could have imperfect and
approximating translations Homer has
chosen to not have Achilles use the
already existing formulas neither the
Ocampa die language that means unstable
furnace though the wording no friend is
not even flimsy ones instead the poet
has his character makeup is owned and
original negative characterization via
the unique formulation there are no
friends in him whatsoever this is the
translation I've ended up preferring
taking pompon as modifying the verb to
be giving it pump on its most emphatic
meaning because it comes at the end of
the sentence and the verse this is a
stronger negative comment on Fernandes
than the language used up to now in the
Iliad and it's perfectly appropriate for
the deep wrenching disappointment
Achilles feels and not being able to
sustain a connection and dialogue with
the person who was dearer to him than
anyone on earth so Homer has Achilles
speak what looks like traditional
language but is in fact subtly
innovative in that the statement I
thought Fernandez look any pump on is a
half a hot box that week order
expression that occurs only once but
Homer is done for Achilles here is not
unlike what Adam Perry said he did for
him in book nine he's given him powers
of expression that take traditional
language beyond the established norms
casting familiar words into new
combinations which brings us back to the
essay by Friedrich and Redfield it's
full title is the language of Achilles
speech as personality symbol there a
central point comparing the speech
habits of Achilles to everyone else in
the Iliad is that Achilles talks
differently from others his speech has
more intensity and forcefulness of
expression with a strong penchant for
extreme and hyperbolic statement a good
example is in book 16 when he tells
Patroclus his wild fantasy wish
if the two of them could be left as the
only ones alive when they conquered Troy
all the Greeks should be dead all the
Trojans should be dead and in same
fantasy for the heroic world because
there'd be no community to give them the
esteem and glory the close that heroes
thrive on and so here in Luke 23 as
Patroclus ghost is fading away
Achilles intensity again drives him to
the rhetoric of extremes because his
friend could not give him the dialogue
you yarns for he dismisses the fading
phantom by saying it was entirely
without minds that had no thinking
whatsoever as Adam Perry argued for
Achilles Beach in book nine the singular
hero tends to say things that are not
normally said in Homeric epic his
thought is exceptional and he creates
original language to say it and he does
not really abuse or misuse the formulaic
diction he adapts it creatively to the
unique circumstance in which he finds
himself the language of Achilles is
always worth examining closely because
he speaks more forcefully and originally
than any other character Adam Perry
broke new ground when he pointed this
out some 57 years ago and the lesson was
so good that we are still learning it
thank you
I guess it's time for questions and some
discussion in this set of things where
one wonders whether the language is
plain the inadequacy of language edison
adequacy of the concepts available to
Nicolay's in language is it playing
that's the moment when he is with prime
and the 10th time has come to recover
Hector's body and I was shocked the
first time I saw this he centrally says
watch out old man I am this close to
killing you right is that just what it
seems to be or is there that's simply
just another symptom of the same
phenomena yeah I changed I'm against it
yeah I wish I had the exact words in for
me but basically as I remember it he's
it's a delicately balanced moment
because the old the enemy King shouldn't
be there like clearly is up it's giving
him back his sons body and it's a very
fragile truce so to speak
and you could feel that Achilles up
who's a impulsive person he's a very
important person is aware that when
tryam asks for a little more than the
Achilles has given all his you might say
his uh his trigger finger is it G that
is he can he's aware that he can react
violently and so here are the sudden
from the friendliness and the empathy in
the scene you're gonna suddenly watch
out
Donaire don't provoke me I didn't look
at the language closely and I don't see
anything
you know I don't recall anything unusual
about it
what I'm intrigued in is you know
language complex emotional situations
whether you see the poet struggling to
find a way or the core complex physical
situations where he has trouble being
clear about what's going on
I guess trouble with simultaneity yes
sometimes some problem with spatial
descriptions of things that are
consistent but because more interesting
for me always is the the emotional life
of people if you know we read novels
nowadays where people are very good at
describing what's going on in people's
minds and Homer was not meant to be
doing that you know it's action poetry
so when you get the introspection and
more so in the Odyssey new ground has to
be broken for what I call the language
of immateriality the interior self is it
so it's alright the scene you're talking
about at a private look at the Greek
text try to figure it is there anything
going on there that's unusual or their
normal patterns that are being stretched
or adapted in ways we can tell you know
distorted in it in a creative way to
stretch for something new I hope that's
enough of an answer thank you I was
really intrigued by the juxtaposition of
the SU high in the Iliad and the Odyssey
and was wondering about Achilles cameo
in the Nick way of the Odyssey do you
think the argument about Achilles
language can tell us something
interesting about Achilles appearance
there well again you know I'd have to
look at the passage in Greek and figure
out just the way the way Richard Martin
did or or there are other unusual words
being used or familiar phrase
combinations being radically or at least
strategically rearranged to say
something a little new that hasn't been
said before it's very risky to say
someone's saying so it hasn't been said
before
when we have a limited body of epic but
it's pretty clear that Homer inherits a
long tradition of essentially action
poetry storytelling and he's a master
storyteller who has more leisure and
interest in deepening character and plot
and relationships and I see that you
know love psychological complexity and
are developing and in both epics in a
way that we can just pretty surely
assume is takes us beyond what previous
poets had done on so you know I'd
probably be looking at the language and
saying are there from phrase patterns
that seem like hot boxes or unique new
combinations based on old language
achilles oh that's it well they just of
course he makes that statement
anti-traditional is anything I'd rather
be basically you know a laborer on earth
then a dead hero in the underworld and
that's the most you know direct
projection of heroic thought you can
imagine so the question is did he have
easy language to say it in look at the
language and see if there are any
awkward juxtapositions or ambiguously
rendered phrases or East he hasn't been
perfectly it's me it was perfectly clear
as I remember that passage so there
there's no problem of saying anti
traditional things in traditional
language because the whole problem is
we've been hampered by mullen Perris and
it's hard to even everyone's are radical
revisionist of Perry it's almost like
with Freud I mean in Orthodox for
audience laughs everyone's a revisionist
to some degree and two wild degrees even
so no one believes that traditional
language was so constraining as moment
Perry argued the matter in Perry himself
in 1920 in 1956 was saying I take my
father's theory as it stands and here
are some implications in Don ten years
later in 66 and the article in yell
Classical Studies he's saying Homer is
not oral doesn't ever say my father was
wrong exactly
but Unitas says all overwrote because
the texture of the language is too fine
the poetry is too good it shows too much
care and premeditation and searching for
the best wording to be orally improvised
a la Yugoslavia although Lord says this
I'm not improvisation that's a you know
Lord always said it's recomposition in
performance which is that an
improvisation maybe isn't a bad word if
you take it the way to jazz jazz player
and problem it provides us on something
he's played a hundred times and all the
court sequences are going to be the same
and the progressions we've said but
he'll add new details if that's what
improvisation means then it's read
composition and performance but people
criticize Lords in you know illiterate
improvisers was one of the- from Douglas
young published in the early article
naming Lords whole theory Oh was a homer
and the literate improviser is what here
and of course not ISA he's too good to
be a simple man who can read and write
it's a good a poet so on about getting
off on another whole other track here
but the the point is the we shouldn't
see a straitjacket you know and now
there's so much of the good work and the
parity as a post para tradition has been
loosening up you know the rigidity of
the first stuff Haynesworth did the
flexibility of the formula showing a
metrical and same expression used for
the same idea regularly in the same
metrical shape is not necessarily true
he's a nice idea words have bonds and
mutual expectation they will Co occur
but not always in the symmetrical
thought you could split a formula you
could decline it you could even put one
word in the next line and that was a
wonderful step forward my structural
formula argument which claimed too much
perhaps I I recant a little bit in my
article in the formula and the Brill
companion to Homer
but basically I thought I saw was but
the Lord said about an analogical
constructions with the same syntax and
substituting either term so you've
substituted both terms yeah that's
totally new expression that's something
formulaic but it's not a parry formula
anymore so there's been a lot of
stretching and loosening and showing a
lot more creativity and then people of
emphasized have many more hot boxes
there are and unique expressions then
Perry would allow for so the but so it
would be fun to see when Achilles does
express the most I think
anti-traditional thing in the whole
corpus Iliad Odyssey is his language do
we see any signs that there was a
struggle in the poet Oh in the way in
the poet composing for a character to
make language in any way that is just
making a forging new language show signs
of strain on syntax grammar of the
neologisms whatever and you know
vocabulary for example in the Odyssey oh
that is just that vicious there's so
much calculating deep planning was just
talking about this with Chris Simon
earlier that he mixes on this new verb
buso D'Mello appears to construct in
your depths the language of inferiority
is a beginning to expand in the the
needs of the Odyssey polish oh I've
always inclined to think it's not the
Iliad poet but you know we'll never know
he's different
for the Pettway either the old guy at a
very new style of storytelling with some
new interests or a deacon guy who is an
apprentice to the first poet but there
is there a lot of differences your
theology and phraseology and formulaic
use and Ivan emphasis you know recently
of noticing in the words of pondering
these words a trend of the depth of the
inner self
um that beaker there is growing in the
Odyssey I know an Italian graduate
students just writing a master's thesis
on that very topic right now and I've
been supervising it you know again be
advising by email which is kind of fun
we can do this nowadays yeah that's
quite young in pert
I was and in that connection I was
thinking about the first two lines of
accusing a great speech the speech when
she says I hate the man similar to the
gates of Hades that hides one thing in
one thing in his friends got a nice
resume and he speaks out of another
thing and in that connection I was
thinking about a more recent proposal to
read this whole embassy scene with
Odysseus and Achilles this is the
message of Agamemnon a proposal to see
that in terms of Achilles not not accept
accepting the terms on which Agamemnon
is giving back all these or giving those
those those presents which hinges on the
notion of ransom and ransom and
reciprocity and in that sense you could
almost say and this doesn't does not
approve but your have been saying that
Achilles is in fact correcting the
speech of Agamemnon knowing the code
better in that Agamemnon is trying to to
do by Achilles back and this is where
the argument of dollar Wilson
so you familiar with that which I
thought was interesting has never been
really applied to the to the discussion
of the language of Achilles because
Agamemnon is proposing something is
hiding something the way he gives back
things while what Achilles is interested
in is not so much all their riches that
he gets from Agamemnon that you can get
from my grandma
but that Agamemnon goes you know suffers
the an eye for an eye a tooth for a
tooth kind of principle he has to
undergo the very same little bad right
the same public insult that Achilles
thinks he has and in that in that sense
I can I can see the accusative of the
Demario lobe and he has to give that
back to me as I'm very forceful and very
very decisive kind of way of speaking
because I don't need a genitive there
you have to get he has to give his
things in exchange for the low bed so he
has to give me pink kingdoms or his
daughter or whatever no he has to give
me the same thing meaning he should
experience the love a same outrageous
righteousness but Achilles in that sense
in fact you can turn it around and he
speaks speaks the the epic language
tries to manipulate it in ways that
writings does not does not accept right
that would that would go very well with
the idea that Achilles is the by far the
best even though he's supposed to be a
fighter he is the is the best speaker
he's the master of a via epic rhetoric
and we think necessary is supposed to be
the hey da Paz and the great operate
this and his speeches are longer and get
boring but but Achilles is the most Al
the best user of language and that's
what Perry said that's what Friedrich
and Renfield say and that's what Martin
says and it's pretty clear yeah I should
look I don't remember Donna Wilson's
argument that as well as I should but
I'll go look at it again because it's
sorry what you said is very interesting
you know it makes sense totally yeah
thank you very much for your talk
doesn't the very fact that you can
pinpoint and describe these moments of
awkward and awkwardness and this
struggle in the language of Achilles
doesn't it suggests that the poet
himself is trying to transcend the
limitations of his language in fact that
his thinking is transcending this
language so actually the lesson that I
take away from your talk is that this is
a profoundly anti-war feein argument
because they're showing that Homer is
not constrained that he is actually
working to work beyond the limitations
of this particular language like he he
can but it's hard
it makes him stumble and say sometimes
ungracious ungraceful things with his
own language that is so fluent elsewhere
when he's describing the usual stuff you
know wounds and spear casts and things
the Worf Ian the modified Worf Ian's
don't say that you can't do certain
things when your language doesn't equip
you well they say that you're slower at
doing them all right but you can catch
up different experiments for example
with the Oh people describe our length
someone we just talked about long as
length and some talk about long as big
and so if you get them to do
measurements I'm that could describe
things got notice like a scientist I'm a
cognitive psychologist they they end up
being better at seeing duration as a
length if the work for long in their
language is one that applies to a rope
being long and they're slower at
perceiving length if the word for big
and they're long and their language
actually really means big broad but each
can learn to think the other's way but
it's a little bit of training so you're
not seriously impaired you're slightly
at a disadvantage by the language you
start with ourself and thinking the
equivalent for two trying in English as
in American is about today in English or
is usually the first name somebody
it's a rough equivalent you know you can
estimate you can gauge when you're ready
to call someone by their first name
instead of mister Ramiz so it's an
instant approximation that's why I think
the the fact the poet can innovate just
the way you can translate grandpa's
house beak became our home you could
find an equivalent it might sound a
little awkward sometimes the expressions
are as I found the I put up a
predominately male a lot being awkward
the some other things that are awkward
the
but you can get there in a coolies case
are what happens is the the limitations
that the friend has our vocabulary would
have given him or transcended
beautifully because he's made up a new
phrase although it's confused people
it's so new and the pompon is
ambiguously played it's ambiguous what
it means so that it's it's both
beautiful and new and a little strange
and that's probably that's what I would
think happens when you're struggling
against Warfield limitations so yeah did
the new Wharf Ian ISM talks about the
subtle differences on that big ones but
the poet who can do anything he wants
the modern poet and say or John Milton
say Shakespeare is not the poet who made
the Iliad or the Odyssey he can do a lot
of what he wants but not all of it and
we see him sometimes uh you know are
awkward and if you read through the
whole thing line by line of they've been
doing lately it's amazing how many some
maybe even my new script errors but
there's so many glitches so many
disfluencies you might call them things
but you don't quite know where the
syntax has gone or that that famous
passage about the Zeus is two urns which
really says there are three urns there
are two urns of evils and one of good
things and everyone translates there are
two urns because they does they can't
stand the awkwardness of saying there
were three and then treating them as - I
think Plato and the Republic since
they're really two urns oh he does not
know if he says maybe as homer is
awkward or he just has to be tell us
what Homer said so there are there were
no in this fluencies galore but they're
they're small and I like them in a way
because of the signs of a live I think a
live oral product
I was very interested by what you said
about tiresias and about the foreigners
being related to his Faculty of
discourse in particular and I was
wondering if the attribution of
foreigners to women as you mentioned
with Chris Harris but also obviously in
the Odyssey to Penelope is is in some
sense the poet trying to attribute them
the power of discourse which we often
see interrupted for example when now to
be stopped by Telemachus or Andromache
by Hector you're asking whether Penelope
is good friends or a poet's attempt to
to do what to give them a sort of a
power of discourse that the the poetry
denies them if Rene's does include this
sort of capacity to create a discourse
if that is something that is being
attributed to women I never hadn't ever
thought of that that's very interesting
Penelope is an exception in every way
because she's so incredibly shrewd and
you know calculating but interesting
think about that because certainly of
talk about women being having a
discourse the press do you think of your
clay are having they have clamped over
her mouth which is about to say you're
Odysseus and then the servants are not
treated well the only woman well now
cicuta has some powers
I think Penelope the question is does
her super are just called Pettifer on
all the time which I just discovered
about ten years ago dawned on me I guess
I was following a Lattimore's idea of
the circumspect petty you know meaning
tentative careful cautious making no
mistakes and getting it right slowly but
petty means above or beyond is like
repair in a lot of America diem like
petit pont au and means above everybody
so but everyone really means exceedingly
with Brenna's I mean you could certainly
were entitled to read it that way
and that would be an
way of strengthening Penelope's friends
which were already a pretty much
strengthened in the poem yeah good nice
idea